now it's under the heading of
multiplying fractions okay so what we
answer this question is going to be
important that we're going to form an
expression equation if you like which
has a multiplication of fractions in it
right don't just put down the answer I
know you want to do it quickly you want
to save space in your book but equally
important I'll make this case even more
strongly later you need to communicate
what your answer means right and you
need more than just one dump on there on
your page to be able to say what's going
on so let's read it together
it says mrs. Dushevina I think that's
hey that's it works seven 3/4 hours a
day so there we go there's our first
piece of information okay she works a
full day each day from Monday to Friday
Monday to Friday and she works a half
day on Saturday so this is important
information that I have down okay the
final answer is how many hours a week
does she work so I'm gonna fall from
these numbers or these pieces of
information a multiplication I'm gonna
solve it and then I'm gonna get an
answer at the end now what kind of for
starters what kind of multiplication am
I going to write I want something times
something and I'm gonna evaluate it yeah
okay they originally said 3/4 time
something right wonder need to work out
is if this is how many I do every day
well how many days do I have that is
half a day here but from Monday to
Friday there are five days right so it
should be times five and a half ok so
right now I know we could go straight to
our calculators do this we will use our
calculators but let's just see how much
we can do before we get to a calculator
okay if I want to multiply fractions
together what do I have to do yes
excellent I want to be able to multiply
numerators at both ones a nominators I
can't really do that as mix do you know
so I'm going to convert into an improper
fraction or improper fractions
no I key tell me what 7 3/4 is as an
improper fraction yeah can you tell me
don't you calculate up how do we do it
how do we do it so we help that all
right well done okay where did the 31
come from it came from 28 plus 3 good
job ok and then of course the other one
five and a half can you do it in your
hand who's got it yeah excellent
ok they go right now that's gonna be a
fraction you can see that when you
multiply the denominators you get over
eight right but yeah 31 times 11 I mean
I probably could do it but this is a
good opportunity to take our calculators
out and just make sure we get the right
number yes so let's do the whole
orientation 31 over 4
make sure you take your cursor out of
the denominator okay yes
I'll get wait for a run to catch up
let's get it just as the calculator says
okay so well we got what is the
calculator say it's gonna give to you as
an improper fraction is it what is it
300 good okay now
yes um question okay now before we get
there why do you think it would be a
good idea to turn this into a big deal
cuz it's you know well we went from here
to here we were trying to get rid of the
mixed D rules right I don't want you to
just know when to convert between them
oh I'm sorry how I want you to know when
like sometimes you go this direction
sometimes you want to go the other
direction why is it a good idea yeah
okay number one the question does
provide it to you these kinds of numbers
but number two have a look exactly at
what they're asking read the question
carefully it says how many hours a week
does she work right so I'm looking for
some number of hours right and this is
this is a we don't looking fraction
right so the button you want to use is
on this one that's above delete right
you want to go shift and you press the
SD button and there's your answer
42 okay there you go now at this point
what do we do and this is sort of where
they are where I got asked the question
cuz it's not a whole number balance
right as fractions involved which I
suppose is not that surprising okay
you've got two alternatives here okay
I'll tell you the simple answer the
first way you can do it is you can say
therefore she works and you just write
down that number including the fraction
write it as a mixed new rule
she works that number or hours okay
however even though it doesn't
specifically ask you here
I mean that's that's kind of weird
people don't tend to say oh you don't
this is um this will take you five
eighths of an hour we tend to say
that'll take some number of minutes
right that's usually the way we speak in
hours minutes so even though the
question does
asked us can we work out how many
minutes this is and the answers we can
think about it this way okay you've got
42 hours but you also have five eighths
of what L okay
is that Alright five eighths of a now
well how many minutes are there in an
hour that we can sandal together right
there's 60 good so I'm gonna say this is
forty two hours I'm gonna leave the
hours alone okay and you don't want to
be joined did this down with me so you
can follow along my working and instead
of one hour over here I'm gonna say five
eighths times 60 minutes five minutes
five 60 minutes because that's what an
hour is so notice this is a bit unusual
we don't tend to do this when we're
measuring lengths or areas it's only to
do it tired we mix units together okay
I've got now is here I've got minute
it's important that I write down both
and again your calculator will help you
out if you put in five eighths and you
multiply it by 60 what does it tell you
and what does it tell you how many
minutes till you 75 over to doesn't it
another improper fraction right but just
like before it'd be nice to have this in
actual whole numbers so you press your
arm your shift and ste button you get 37
and a half okay now this is an
improvement right I don't have this
weird fraction here I've got minutes now
if I go a little further car no because
I've still got a fractured here yes so I
could say 42 hours 37 minutes and this
half means half a minute where you can
tell me how long half a minute is that's
30 seconds okay now can I just emphasize
the question did not ask us to do this I
think if you stopped here that'll be
fine okay
but the fact is you we understand time
quite well right so you can see how I
got this and how I used fractions to
demonstrate it